[Music]
good meme good intro today we're going
to review green text means yes that's
right the funny read it mean people
discover that if you write on reddit
with a greater than sign the text turns
green how cool is that so people started
using it for ways to write funny stories
or perhaps share embarrassing moments
from their past if you don't know what
I'm talking about here's a great example
sex ed teacher eight years ago
told us to be careful when having sex
never have sex how about that one mrs.
Smith that's right how about that gotcha
did not be at Swedish ship crews having
defecated in a week week at least three
giant Python in the toilet try to flush
not working dot jpg panic try to flush
again but doesn't flush look for a
cleaner lady in the hallway Swedish is
really bad so grab the hand of cleaner
and take her to the bathroom try to
flush and say kick back watch in Swedish
well push the flush button goes quite oh
[Music]
did this happened to me I feel like it
had it could have it could have happened
to the best of us I feel like at least
everyone has a really great story you
know what I mean
watch several Isis videos because I love
gore okay the song that plays in them
gets stuck in my head start humming it
to myself at work
Muslim co-worker puts his hand on my
shoulder and it says soon brother soon
lay in hospital bed family is
surrounding you everyone crying let out
your tear life is flashing through your
eyes 50 years of hardcore porn in one
millisecond not all over everyone your
last words are let out last breath die
this is why you all need to stop
watching porn
be fat go to fit and find a solution
main problem is I eat like a dumpster
apparently things with loads of fiber is
going to save my filthy soul fibrous
digested slowly leaving you feeling full
longer and it helps with digestion go
out and buy two boxes of fiber heavy
breakfast bars the first day I have
fiber bars for breakfast lunch and lots
of snacks I don't change that day next
day I fibre myself up even more I don't
use that day either fiber Jesus is
surely worth this magic in my colon can
feel pounds dropping off because I'm not
very hungry anymore
I don't use the third day I don't lose
the fourth day the final days dawns mp3
I have my morning coffee I feel my
insides rumble in that familiar way the
second I hit the toilet the weirdest
fart in the world exits me its whistling
just a thin continuous air stream of
fart that smells like grandpa posh
coughing no sound other than the
whistling hiss suddenly stops the hole
is plugged X OS this is so solid it
feels like I'm giving anal birth to
Dwayne the rock Johnson hang on the
shower
and pray the rock is shut out of my own
soul and machspeed my entire ass is
covered in toilet water
now the fun begins a fun thought that
could do more damage to the ozone layer
than aerosols ever did is shooting
bullets after me solid and perfectly
round August the smell is killing me
blacking out that shots of nuggets
shooting around the bull propelled by my
eight insane fiber flatulence he's
giving me war flashback I wasn't even in
Nam jpg' my guts are yelling in German
sounds like a mousse in heat lives in my
belly
most of the isn't even digested at his
point just forced out by all the gas
that I'd been building up by my throat
after an hour it finally seems to be
over I'm shivering and crying both legs
collapse as I Strider stand up my
stomach hitting the bathroom tiles
forces one last trumpet Gondor calls for
aid our our shakily wipes my ass
completely clean
go on akinator say yes when asked if
your character is a porn star answer in
accordance to what you want your porn
star to look like akinator gives you a
hand-picked porn star to fit your prior
preferences why do I wear the headphones
this genius akinator help me find my
dream wife does it work with anime girls
it's your character older than
probably okay apparently I have found my
enemy wife
sorry Marcia the year 2014
women rule the world rihanna is their
leader we stuck in concentration camp
for me
rihanna killing all the dudes because
they found a way to reproduce without a
group of us overpower garden sis be
running get surrounded sand of PNG all
of a sudden a masked hero appears with
his schlong flapping in the wind beats
up all the women that's all in the dudes
free
many things takes
it was Chris Brown Oh I [ __ ] up big
time boys be happily married for six
years wife and I call each other cute
pet names more than our real names
introduce us both at a function I'm
Annan and this is my wife sweet [ __ ]
christ JP that face when I don't my face
when she's making me sleep in the
backyard I got a story about this b12
six great really need to piss excuse
myself from band class rush to bathroom
it's all the way on the other side of
the school discretely holding my clothes
as I do arrive decide to kick down stall
door like I'm in the movies it's
occupied kid frog style with both feet
on the toilet seat what thing is turned
quickly retract into his rectum like a
scared turtle the scare causes me to
pull myself my face when make a friend
while playing team fortress 2 never
really had a video friend before we
played together often talk about life a
bit to him and jerseys had a girlfriend
for about four years
one day says he's going to propose to
her give him some encouragement next day
he's all mine he says she rejected him
tried to be supportive of him he spirals
into depression spends all his time
playing videa for a few months one day
he tells me that he's planning to commit
suicide talk to him for a few days see
if he's really serious about it realize
I can't talk him out of it he stopped
going to his job after his girlfriend
dumped him just became a recluse with no
will to live
wish him the best in the afterlife and
say goodbye last online 1760 four days
ago big op Nick be effing dumped need to
form a sentence to get attention from
people squats are circulation to your
legs actually denied more blood go to
your brain you can actually make
sentences usage alert people closer get
up and start punching the [ __ ] out of
that that's right
the reason Matty the SWAT is so you can
have more blood into your pumped into
your brain what are you stupid
this is the body movement of
intellectuals true thinkers but yeah try
out the green texting is really cool he
works on every websites ever so just let
me know if you had get on with it and
remember to like if you enjoyed check
out another video and as always
[Music]
whenever I'm done with its past to make
the Edgar